coat of arms family crest
heraldry what do these names mean and
what are the differences
the image you see before you is not a
coat of arms
nor a family crest okay okay i hear you
say
so what is it what are coats of arms and
what are family crests
and where do these things come from we
see them all over but what do they mean
all good questions and i'm here to
answer them first of all
this entire image is called a heraldic
achievement the term code of arms only
refers to the image
within the shield the reason it's called
a coat of arms is because the design
would often be worn on an actual coat
called a tabard
next up family crest often people will
call this entire image a crest
but it's not the crest is only the small
image atop the helmet you see here
heraldry
is the use of designs typically on
shields
that represent a person family or
organization
heraldry proper where specific people or
families had a unique heraldic design
didn't start until the high middle ages
around the 12th century that said
designs on shields go back to classical
antiquity
conventional wisdom states that this
practice started as a way of telling
soldiers apart during a battle so that
warriors on the same side of a conflict
wouldn't kill each other this
seems to make a lot of sense and it may
well be true in some cases
but a lot of scholars dispute it as it
has little to no evidence to back it up
the designs would have been there for
other reasons
like decoration a way to strike fear in
an opponent
or as a show status besides much of the
time
soldiers in the medieval period had to
acquire their own supplies
so uniformity was uncommon anyway the
practice became popular
and eventually certain individuals
became known for having
specific designs on their shields
richard the lion heart for instance was
known to have
lions on his shield as did geoffrey
plantagenet
the count of anju with the rising
popularity of these designs
knights and noblemen started to adopt
the practice and inevitably argue over
who had the right to specific designs
this caused the powers that be
specifically the kings of europe to
develop governing bodies that tracked
and handed out these designs
so as to keep them unique with this the
title of herald was created
a position tasked with knowing the ranks
and achievements of the knights that
would come to the castle
as well as design and award heraldic
achievements this practice developed
into the college of arms
which still exists to this day in
britain the achievement is composed of
eight parts
the shield the helm the torse the crest
the supporters the compartment and the
motto the shield contains the field
and the images depicted on the field are
called charges
the term tincture refers to the colors
used
in the design the names of these
tinctures as well as the language
surrounding all of heraldry
is a kind of anglicized norman french
traditionally
there are seven main tinctures two
metals
or gold and argent silver then
there are five colors ghouls red azure
blue vert green sable black
and pure purple furs are tinctures meant
to resemble
animal furs worn by noblemen there are
two main furs
hermann which mimics the fur of a weasel
and
there which mimics the fur of a squirrel
over time
three more colors were added these were
known as stains
sanguine blood red murray mulberry and
tane a sort of burnt orange lastly there
are some non-traditional tinctures that
have developed in the 20th century
the most common being blue celeste a sky
blue
carnation a caucasian flesh tone rose
and sandre a grey the rule of tinctures
is the most important part of heraldic
design
it is simple stating that metals shall
not be placed atop
metals and colors shall not be atop
colors so a design like this would not
be allowed
but a design like that would there are
exceptions to the rule
for instance when the shield is divided
the tinctures are seen as
beside one another not atop also when a
charge is depicted as
proper meaning its natural color the
rule does not apply there are also
certain historical exceptions where the
rule was simply not
followed like for the kingdom of
jerusalem also
stains in this case are seen as colors
and furs don't come into the equation at
all also
interestingly blue celeste is seen as a
metal presumably because of its light
color the field itself can be divided a
number of ways
with a variety of dividing lines it can
be divided in two
or three or more there are also what are
called variations of the field
like so now let's move to the charges to
reiterate
charges are images put on the field of
the shield
to start off there are the ordinaries
these are the most common charges and
they consist mostly of geometric shapes
and are similar to divisions and
variations other than the ordinaries
common charges include crosses animals
flowers body parts celestial bodies and
objects
charges can have multiple meanings a
tree in one achievement might mean
strength while on another it may signify
a specific tree in a certain place
some common meanings for common charges
do
exist however lines tend to represent
courage and royalty
crosses of course represent christian
faith books are often
found on the arms of schools and
universities as it represents knowledge
keys are found on the arms of clergymen
as they hold the keys to the church
to properly describe an achievement is
to blaze in it
the blazon is a kind of insider
shorthand to quickly describe the design
on the shield
for instance the blazon of my own family
coat of arms is as follows
azure two bars ore in chief across
formefiche of the last azure means the
field is blue
two bars describes these ordinaries or
means they are gold chief is the term of
the top middle position of the field
and it is a cross the terms forme and
fije are more heraldry speak
describing its shape and of the last
means
the cross is the same color of the last
charge
mentioned which were the gold bars so
the cross is also gold
so now that we're finally down with a
shield what about the rest let's start
with the supporters
the supporters are the figures on either
side of the shield holding up or
supporting the shield
generally they are animals but sometimes
you'll see human figures or even
buildings used
certain animals have connections to
certain nations most famously
lions stand for england and unicorns for
scotland
supporters stand on the compartment
usually
a small landscape it's important to
point out that supporters are not seen
on every achievement
in fact they're not seen on most
achievements and are only given to those
of high status
or as an award for a special service the
helm is set atop the shield
traditionally the type of helm didn't
really mean anything but as heraldry
developed different styles of helm
started to symbolize different ranks
for instance an open visored helm means
nobility or royalty
a closed visor means lower nobility or
gentry women and clergymen generally do
not have helms on their achievements
as they would not go to war the taurus
is a circle of cloth above the helm
royalty and nobility will generally have
a crown or coronet instead above the
taurus is the crest
crests came from the practice of knights
having fanciful objects atop their helms
usually for tournaments like charges
they can represent different things
crests were sometimes used as badges
which gave rise to the misnomer of
crests referring to the entire
achievement
mantling is the cloth around the helm
again this comes from the way knights
would be
armored and dressed it is generally
simply decorative lastly is the motto
a motto would not be given as much as
chosen by the person or family receiving
the arms
often it would be added years or
generations later
also mottos were usually in latin so now
that you know the different parts of the
achievement
you may want to go and find your own
family coat of arms if you have one
or design your own well a couple of
words of warning on how to spot bogus
arms
that will also help you design genuine
looking arms
first off official achievements are
given out by official
organizations if you live in a country
with one of those
making unofficial arms might be seen as
disrespectful or ill-advised
you may be able to petition for official
arms if so desired
moving on to spotting fake achievements
first if the rules of
tinctures are not followed it probably
isn't official
second crowns or other royal charges
used when clearly not deserved
is a red flag third thin crosses or
other thin
incorrect divisions fourth supporters
not in a compartment
and last use of cliche charges like
lions or fleur-de-lis
obviously these are not hard and fast
rules especially with the cliche charges
they are cliche for a reason after all
they all have exceptions
but if you see multiple red flags
understand the achievement probably
isn't official
now go forth with understanding and
knowledge of this small but very cool
aspect of european history
thanks for watching
you